Hey everybody, we're here with 110th episode, which is pretty exciting. And we have a guest today. Oh, yeah, go ahead. You want to celebrate? I was just saying, yeah. So we're here with a guest today, Dotan, and you are CEO of Spectral. Why don't you go ahead and introduce yourself briefly, and then we'll get started. Yeah.
大家好，我们迎来了第110期节目，这非常令人兴奋。今天我们有一位嘉宾。哦，对了，请继续。你想庆祝一下吗？我只是想说，是的。所以我们今天有一位嘉宾，Dotan，你是Spectral的首席执行官。不如你先简单介绍一下自己，然后我们就开始吧。好的。
So hi, guys. So I'm Dotan. And by the way, 110 is binary, right? Oh, there we go. That's right. You didn't see that. How did we miss that? So yeah, so I'm Dotan, CEO of Spectral.
大家好。我是Dotan。顺便说一下，110是二进制，对吧？哦，原来如此。没错。你没看出来。我们怎么会错过这个呢？所以，我是Dotan，Spectral的首席执行官。
It's a cybersecurity company geared toward developers. I mean, we like to say that we create tools for developers with security as a side effect. So yeah, so that's what our focus is. Awesome. Well, I mean, I guess that's a lot to unpack. So I think everybody would agree security is very important, but maybe everyone doesn't understand what security is.
这是一家面向开发者的网络安全公司。我的意思是，我们喜欢说我们为开发者创造工具，而安全性只是一个副产品。所以，这就是我们的重点。太棒了。嗯，我想这有很多内容需要展开。我想大家都会同意安全性非常重要，但也许并不是每个人都理解什么是安全性。
So we were talking about this a little when we were doing during warmup. So if we talk about security, does that mean that you are developing antivirus for computers for developers? Or does it mean something more? Yeah, I mean, it's kind of all goes back to, I guess, evolution of our,
我们在热身时稍微讨论过这个问题。所以如果我们谈论安全性，这是否意味着你们正在为开发者的电脑开发杀毒软件？还是说它意味着更多？是的，我的意思是，这一切都回到了，我想，我们领域的演变，
I guess it is our domain, our world, which is kind of high-tech or software world. Time really gets compact with all these revolutions. We have evolution and revolution. So, I mean, if you go back to 2007, that was just before Facebook and just before iPhone I guess and if you go back to 2005 that that was before the rise of Microsoft I guess the major rise of Microsoft as a dot-net shop which really made you know made all the enterprise software come along. And then kind of 98, 2000, the first bubble. So all these stages, they had, it's kind of a sprint to create technology.
我想这就是我们的领域，我们的世界，也就是所谓的高科技或软件世界。随着所有这些革命，时间真的变得紧凑了。我们有演变和革命。所以，如果你回到2007年，那是在Facebook和iPhone出现之前，我想如果你回到2005年，那是微软崛起之前，我想是微软作为.net商店的主要崛起，这确实让所有的企业软件随之而来。然后是98年、2000年，第一次泡沫。所以所有这些阶段，它们都有，这是一种创造技术的冲刺。
And the focus is on creating technology that is supposed to give developers productivity and supposed to make companies very productive and create a very nice portfolio of products. And almost always, I mean, maybe not intentionally, but almost always the security side of things was kind of left behind. You know, I'm sure no one intended for it to be, but there's a lot of more velocity under creating a great product at the time at each and every step of this,
重点是创造旨在为开发者提供生产力、旨在使公司非常高效并创造出非常好的产品组合的技术。而且几乎总是，我的意思是，也许不是故意的，但几乎总是安全方面被抛在了后面。你知道，我相信没有人打算这样做，但在当时，在每一个步骤中，创造伟大产品所带来的速度要快得多，
like in the first bubble and then in 2005 and then into 2007 and so on, rather than, okay, so let's create the technology and a product and let's create the technology and a product, and let's also make it, you know, kind of dependent on making great security be there for us. So almost every time security came after the revolution, after the evolution.
就像在第一次泡沫中，然后在2005年，再到2007年等等，而不是，好吧，让我们创造技术和产品，让我们也让它，你知道，某种程度上依赖于让伟大的安全性为我们所用。所以几乎每一次，安全性都出现在革命之后，演变之后。
So we had from simple firewalls to intrusion detection, which is, you know, the large kind of systems that try their best to find anomalies in the area of 2000, to the smarter firewalls. And even today, those like this mini kind of firewalls of WAFs that you integrate as an SDK into your app. So yeah, so it comes in waves, technology, and then security comes in waves as well. And yeah, so the latest we're seeing right now in terms of the evolution of software
所以我们经历了从简单的防火墙到入侵检测，也就是，你知道，那些尽最大努力在2000年左右发现异常的大型系统，再到更智能的防火墙。即使在今天，那些像WAF这样的小型防火墙，你作为SDK集成到你的应用程序中。所以是的，它是分波段出现的，技术，然后安全性也分波段出现。所以是的，我们现在看到的软件演变的最新情况
is that, yeah, we know that software eats the world, but we are kind of feeling that it already ate the world. So, you know, you can do so much today that you couldn't have done, I mean, as little as three or four years ago, actually. You know, you can take a Lambda and you can pick up a bunch of SaaS services and you're done. I mean, you build a product that used to be maybe three, four, five years ago, you know, used to take much more energy to build.
是，是的，我们知道软件正在吞噬世界，但我们感觉它已经吞噬了世界。所以，你知道，你今天能做很多三四年前根本做不到的事情。你知道，你可以使用Lambda，你可以挑选一堆SaaS服务，然后就完成了。我的意思是，你构建了一个产品，在三、四、五年前，你知道，构建它需要更多的精力。
So in that sense, as a developer, you have so much more power and so many more paths to get to the same end goal that i'm not sure i mean i feel it for myself i'm not sure the security world can even begin to realize because they need i mean if we if we think about them as they, then they need to understand how to develop as well as developers in order to give, to create great solutions for that developer that glues stuff together and, you know, invent stuff from existing parts. Yeah, that makes a bunch of sense. I'd say, yeah, that covered, I mean, you went to the whole history of modern or last couple
所以从这个意义上说，作为一名开发者，你拥有更多的力量和更多的路径来实现同一个最终目标，我不确定，我的意思是，我自己也有这种感觉，我不确定安全世界是否能开始意识到这一点，因为他们需要，我的意思是，如果我们把他们看作“他们”，那么他们也需要像开发者一样了解如何开发，以便为那个将东西粘合在一起并从现有部件中发明东西的开发者创造出伟大的解决方案。是的，这很有道理。我想说，是的，这涵盖了，我的意思是，你回顾了现代或过去几十年计算机软件的整个历史。
decades of computer software there. But I was going to say, so one through the whole history of modern or last couple decades of computer software there. But I was going to say, so one of the interesting things, I think, before we get into the kind of specifics about what needs to be secured, this kind of thing you mentioned where people build a product first and then try to figure out security later. I guess that's an interesting balance where if you're building something until it's built, maybe it doesn't really need security, right? If it's just a thought in my head, I don't need security. If people are going to start using it though, immediately you need to start having some amount of security. Do you have opinion on like, what is the balance there? So if you don't know yet what you're doing and what may be your risks, when is
但我正想说，所以其中一个有趣的事情，我认为，在我们进入关于需要保护什么的具体细节之前，你提到的这种人们先构建产品然后试图在以后弄清楚安全性的方式。我想这是一种有趣的平衡，如果你在构建某样东西直到它建成，也许它并不真正需要安全性，对吧？如果它只是我脑子里的一个想法，我不需要安全性。但如果人们开始使用它，你立刻就需要开始拥有一定程度的安全性。你对那里的平衡有什么看法吗？所以如果你还不知道你在做什么以及你的风险可能是什么，什么时候
the right time to start considering security? And what are some of the good, you know, first things to start considering? Yeah, so that's a great, great question. I mean, I think the balance is shifting towards really taking the time in development time, in design time and think about security on the security model. So, you know, this was kind of theoretical. Yeah, everyone should do threat modeling and everyone should do secure by design and so on. And frankly, you know, you'll find these people
是开始考虑安全性的正确时机？以及一些好的、你知道，开始考虑的第一件事是什么？是的，这是一个非常非常好的问题。我的意思是，我认为平衡正在转向真正花时间在开发时间、设计时间上，并考虑安全性或安全模型。所以，你知道，这在某种程度上是理论上的。是的，每个人都应该做威胁建模，每个人都应该做安全设计等等。坦率地说，你知道，你会发现这些人
who are extremely into security that are actually doing these things. But the thing is, it wasn't being done properly or, you know, by everyone as kind of a development workflow. You know, when you come to develop a feature, then you have the design and you have maybe a POC and you're supposed to have this small or maybe large threat modeling box, but no one actually does it. Or most people kind of focus on the other areas of developing a new feature. product and pushing it into your traditional server farm or your really secure and isolated cloud operation, whatever.
对安全性非常投入，他们实际上正在做这些事情。但问题是，它并没有被正确地执行，或者，你知道，被每个人作为一种开发工作流程来执行。你知道，当你来开发一个功能时，你有设计，你可能有POC，你应该有这个小的或者也许大的威胁建模框，但没有人真正去做。或者大多数人倾向于关注开发新功能的其他领域。产品并将其推送到你传统的服务器场或你非常安全和隔离的云操作中，无论是什么。
And you're pretty sure that within this closed garden, even if you didn't do the proper threat modeling as a developer, then things will be okay. However, this kind of understanding is changing because it's no longer pushing to a server or to a kind of a closed garden environment. It's, you know, taking your function and placing it somewhere. And now someone can ask a question, which is, I don't know, I don't have the answer. If I push a function to whatever, you know, I don't want to name any service, but, you know, it's kind of any of the new hip, cool services out there that really make you productive. If you push that function, did the other side do everything they need to do in terms of
而且你很确定在这个封闭的花园里，即使你作为开发者没有做适当的威胁建模，事情也会没问题。然而，这种理解正在改变，因为它不再是推送到服务器或某种封闭的花园环境。它是，你知道，把你的函数放在某个地方。现在有人可以问一个问题，就是，我不知道，我没有答案。如果我把一个函数推送到任何，你知道，我不想点名任何服务，但是，你知道，它是任何新的时髦的、很酷的服务，确实让你高效。如果你推送到那个函数，对方是否做了他们需要做的关于
the traditional threat modeling to keep you safe? Are they obligated to do it? Do they have, let's say, a WAF to identify SQL injections for you, maybe, or maybe to drop someone who's attacking your service and so on? I'm not sure, actually. So it kind of shifts the responsibility to the developer because you're building a function, you're dropping it on whatever cloud provider, and your function is now live. It's up to you, right? Yeah. So I guess you were talking about deploying these functions and applications to public
传统的威胁建模来保证你的安全？他们有义务这样做吗？他们有，比如说，一个WAF来为你识别SQL注入，也许，或者也许来丢弃攻击你服务的人等等？我其实不确定。所以它在某种程度上将责任转移给了开发者，因为你正在构建一个函数，你把它放在任何云提供商上，你的函数现在就上线了。这取决于你，对吧？是的。所以我猜你在谈论将这些函数和应用程序部署到公共
facing cloud. Or do you think that the same applies to internally deployed app like enterprise software that would just be used sort of within your corporate firewalls? I think you were sort of referring to this when you mentioned walled garden approaches. Right, right. I think you were sort of referring to this when you mentioned walled garden approaches. Right. Right. So I believe like eventually the enterprises, the closed enterprises really adopt whatever is happening on the open, let's say, on the open wild world. So, you know, maybe we need to give one realistic example.
面向的云。或者你认为同样的情况也适用于内部部署的应用程序，比如企业软件，它只是在你的企业防火墙内使用？我想当你提到围墙花园方法时，你是在指这个。对，对。我想当你提到围墙花园方法时，你是在指这个。对。对。所以我相信最终企业，封闭的企业确实采用了开放的，比如说，开放的狂野世界中正在发生的一切。所以，你知道，也许我们需要给出一个现实的例子。
So let's say I'm working at kind of an Acme Corp, some kind of corporation, doesn't matter. And I'm a developer and basically I have, you know, this service, small service to build. And I decide to build it on, I don't know, Heroku or I don't know, Verso. I do that. No one is stopping me.
所以假设我在某个Acme公司工作，某种公司，没关系。我是一名开发者，基本上我有，你知道，这个服务，要构建的小服务。我决定在，我不知道，Heroku或者我不知道，Vercel上构建它。我做了。没有人阻止我。
I can do it. And then I can plug it into my existing infrastructure inside the corporation. And I don't know if that would be something that is okay. I mean, as a developer, I'm just, you know, shipping software. But here's something that, you know, an ability or a possibility that wasn't there five years ago. You know, Heroku was there, but the culture of shipping things fast and being able to take things to the, you know,
我可以这样做。然后我可以把它插入到公司内部现有的基础设施中。我不知道那是否是可以的事情。我的意思是，作为一名开发者，我只是，你知道，交付软件。但这里有一些，你知道，五年前不存在的能力或可能性。你知道，Heroku在那里，但快速交付东西并能够把东西带到，你知道，
to the extreme end-to-end wasn't there. So here's one path that is now open, and now people can actually wake up tomorrow and figure out, scan their code and look for external services that exist in the code base and try to figure out how many are there that they know of and how many are there that they don't know of. And that's just SaaS services. Now you can take the same analogy and try to think about what kind of libraries do you use?
到极端的端到端文化并不存在。所以这是一个现在开放的路径，现在人们实际上可以在明天醒来并弄清楚，扫描他们的代码并寻找代码库中存在的外部服务，并试图弄清楚他们知道的有多少，他们不知道的有多少。而那只是SaaS服务。现在你可以采用同样的类比，试着思考你使用什么样的库？
And everyone remembers LeftPad, right? When it was just suddenly pulled out of NPM, breaking half the internet. That's kind of the new world that's happening in the last few years that I'm not sure everyone are ready for. So what would be an example of, like you mentioned, building a Heroku-based application, deploying it and scanning for what services that you may not have realized? Do you have examples there of what would be something that you may not intend to have exposed that got exposed?
每个人都记得LeftPad，对吧？当它突然从NPM中被拉出时，破坏了半个互联网。这就是过去几年发生的新世界，我不确定每个人都准备好了。那么，你提到的构建基于Heroku的应用程序，部署它并扫描你可能没有意识到的服务，会是一个什么样的例子？你有什么例子说明你可能不打算暴露但被暴露的东西吗？
Oh, yeah. I mean, well, first there's this kind of the cyber world, call it shadow IT, where people basically, what they want to do is be more productive inside the organization. So it's kind of two sides of the coin. One is positive, one is negative. And the positive side is you have a team that thinks it can move quickly
哦，是的。我的意思是，好吧，首先有这种网络世界，称之为影子IT，人们基本上，他们想做的是在组织内部更有效率。所以这有点像硬币的两面。一个是积极的，一个是消极的。积极的一面是，你有一个团队认为它可以快速行动
and adopts, you know, unvetted software, so to speak, and then ships it to production and that creates a bunch of you know it assets i don't know services services whatever you you whatever you can think of that actually no one knows exists in production on the other side if from a cyber perspective that is an unauthorized use of software, which is kind of giving it a kind of a warfare kind of name, like a shadow IT, like shadow ops. So this example, you know, if you guys even check your stuff,
并采用，你知道，未经审查的软件，可以这么说，然后将其发布到生产环境，这会产生一堆你知道的IT资产，我不知道服务、服务，无论你，无论你能想到什么，实际上没有人知道它存在于生产环境中。另一方面，从网络角度来看，这是对软件的未经授权的使用，这有点像给它一个战争的名字，比如影子IT，比如影子操作。所以这个例子，你知道，如果你们甚至检查你们的东西，
then maybe you can find many examples of that. But, you know, it's kind of a productivity thing. Yeah, I think, so maybe just stepping back a bit, it'd be really good to explain to folks what are the different components of computer security? What actually a firewall is and how to protect against, like what is a SQL injection? What are the kind of threats that you encounter and how do those things work? Oh yeah, so I think, first of all,
那么也许你可以找到很多这样的例子。但是，你知道，这是一种生产力的事情。是的，我想，所以也许稍微退后一步，向人们解释计算机安全的不同组成部分会非常好。防火墙到底是什么，以及如何防止，比如什么是SQL注入？你遇到的威胁是什么，这些东西是如何工作的？哦，是的，所以我想，首先，
let's try to get the motives out there, right? So there's hackers and there's the good people and bad people, right? So to speak. So I guess developer build software and they're trying their best to actually add value and the hackers try to, I don't know, remove value or try to gain the system and gain some profit really quickly. So basically when I build, for example, when I build a function, I don't know, that takes a parameter from a URL from a website and, you know, maybe it's a page number, you know, traditional paging feature.
让我们试着把动机摆出来，对吧？所以有黑客，有善良的人和坏人，对吧？可以这么说。所以我猜开发者构建软件，他们正在尽最大努力实际上增加价值，而黑客试图，我不知道，移除价值或试图利用系统并非常快地获得一些利润。所以基本上当我构建时，例如，当我构建一个函数，我不知道，它从网站的URL中获取一个参数，你知道，也许它是一个页码，你知道，传统的分页功能。
Then I take this parameter and I, you know, inject it into an SQL query that I have on my backend. And my goal is to just give you page number two. So that's, you know, that's my perspective as a developer. I see nothing, you know, no harm done. I mean, I'm taking a value and dropping it inside a string, which contains an SQL query, and I'm done. Like I push this feature, I go home and that's it. But the other side of it is that when a hacker looks at it, then first of all, there's what is it for me? Like what's there to gain? But first of all, the company needs to be really attractive
然后我获取这个参数，我，你知道，把它注入到我在后端拥有的SQL查询中。我的目标只是给你第二页。所以这就是，你知道，我作为开发者的视角。我什么也没看到，你知道，没有造成伤害。我的意思是，我正在获取一个值并把它丢进一个字符串中，其中包含一个SQL查询，然后我就完成了。就像我发布了这个功能，我回家，就这样。但它的另一面是，当黑客看到它时，首先，有什么好处？比如有什么可获得的？但首先，公司需要非常有吸引力
in terms of hacking anything. And there has to be some kind of trophy on the other side. So if I'm looking at something, at some company as a hacker, and I realize they might have sensitive data because they're, I don't know, healthcare, whatever, then at least I have now the motive or incentive to actually try to figure out where can I hack into. So looking at this naive SQL thing that developer just built. So I'm looking at the parameter and what I'm trying to do is take, instead of giving the parameter what it expects, which is a number, I'll try as a hacker to, you know, try to inject some malicious SQL code.
在黑客攻击任何东西方面。而且另一边必须有某种奖杯。所以如果我作为一个黑客在看某样东西，在看某家公司，我意识到他们可能有敏感数据，因为他们是，我不知道，医疗保健，无论什么，那么至少我现在有了动机或激励去真正尝试弄清楚我可以在哪里进行黑客攻击。所以看着这个开发者刚刚构建的幼稚的SQL东西。所以我正在看这个参数，我试图做的是，而不是给参数它所期望的东西，也就是一个数字，我会作为一个黑客尝试，你知道，尝试注入一些恶意的SQL代码。
Maybe if I'm in for doing some damage, maybe I'll try some drop tables instead of a number. If I have reason to believe that the backend will actually give me the results as I wanted, then I'll try to inject an actual query into the number instead of a number. And what I'll hope for is for the developer not to actually be defensive, which means the developer forgot or didn't bother to actually sanitize the parameters and make sure that if the developer expects a number, there only should be a number there.
也许如果我打算做一些破坏，也许我会尝试一些删除表而不是数字。如果我有理由相信后端实际上会给我我想要的结果，那么我会尝试在数字中注入一个实际的查询而不是一个数字。而我所希望的是开发者实际上不是防御性的，这意味着开发者忘记了或者没有费心去真正清理参数，并确保如果开发者期望一个数字，那里应该只有一个数字。
So that is kind of the gist of SQL injection. So this is one kind of attack. So just a little bit about firewalls. So basically a firewall is something that sits between a machine and the outside internet or maybe internal internet, doesn't matter, the outside world. And what it tries to do is to monitor traffic and figure out which traffic is strange and which traffic is normal. So it used to be, you know, it used to be very simple.
所以这就是SQL注入的要点。所以这是攻击的一种。所以关于防火墙的一点点。所以基本上防火墙是位于机器和外部互联网之间，或者也许是内部互联网，没关系，外部世界之间的东西。它试图做的是监控流量并弄清楚哪些流量是奇怪的，哪些流量是正常的。所以它曾经是，你知道，它曾经非常简单。
It used to be basically looking at open ports and trying to block irregular ports on machines. That is like 20 years ago. And today it's a lot smarter. So today a firewall is maybe not the correct name anymore, but it's a system that looks at anomalies in your traffic. And that is, the acronym is WAF, which is Web Application Firewall. So many cloud providers have that, and you can actually flip a switch and have it as a feature. And basically, it looks at your traffic,
它曾经基本上是查看开放端口并试图阻止机器上的不规则端口。那是20年前的事了。而今天它聪明多了。所以今天防火墙也许不再是正确的名字了，但它是一个查看你流量中异常的系统。这就是，缩写是WAF，也就是Web应用防火墙。所以很多云提供商都有这个，你实际上可以拨动一个开关并把它作为一个功能。基本上，它查看你的流量，
and it can recognize what is normal and what is not normal. And usually, that is backed by some kind of machine learning. So yeah, so these are two categories, I guess, of attacks. And basically, the reality is that the amount of attacks always grows. There are always new attacks because there's always new code and there's always new features and new products being launched. That make sense? Yeah.
它可以识别什么是正常的，什么是不正常的。通常，这是由某种机器学习支持的。所以是的，我想这是攻击的两个类别。基本上，现实是攻击的数量总是在增长。总是有新的攻击，因为总是有新的代码，总是有新的功能和新的产品被推出。这有道理吗？是的。
So you mentioned this, the WAFTA's web application framework and trying to understand what is questionable traffic. So if you're deploying some new website, some new API, and it doesn't kind of know what to expect, how does it understand what is questionable and what is considered pretty normal traffic? Right. So there's, I guess, like in every machine learning operation, there's the cold boot
所以你提到了这个，WAFTA是Web应用框架，并试图理解什么是可疑流量。所以如果你正在部署一些新的网站，一些新的API，而它不知道该期待什么，它如何理解什么是可疑的，什么被认为是相当正常的流量？对。所以有，我想，就像在每个机器学习操作中一样，有冷启动
problem. So if you have something new, then obviously it hasn't yet learned enough traffic to tell you what's normal and what's not. But luckily, I guess if someone would look at most of the internet traffic, they'll realize there's like clusters of normal traffic and there's cluster of irregular traffic. So, and again, probably this is, you know, the secret recipe of every different vendor of such firewalls. Fair enough. But yeah, but, but, you know, the generic case is that there's normal behavior and you have so much traffic
问题。所以如果你有新的东西，那么显然它还没有学习足够的流量来告诉你什么是正常的，什么不是。但幸运的是，我想如果有人查看大多数互联网流量，他们会意识到有像正常流量的集群，也有不规则流量的集群。所以，而且再次，这可能是，你知道，每个此类防火墙的不同供应商的秘方。很有道理。但是的，但是，你知道，一般情况是存在正常行为，而且你有这么多流量
these days, public traffic and so on that you can analyze and build on. And there's like irregular traffic that is very specific to a certain service. And I can tell you from experience that, yeah, definitely it takes time for these technologies to actually learn what is normal. And you get a small amount of false positives at the beginning. But the good news is that if you have traffic, then it learns. And if you don't have traffic, then maybe this service is not that popular or risky because you don't have traffic.
这些天，公共流量等等，你可以分析并建立在上面。而且有非常特定于某个服务的不规则流量。我可以凭经验告诉你，是的，这些技术确实需要时间来真正学习什么是正常的。你一开始会得到少量的误报。但好消息是，如果你有流量，那么它就会学习。如果你没有流量，那么也许这个服务不是那么受欢迎或有风险，因为你没有流量。
So yeah, so in this specific case, it kind of of it kind of creates a nice a nice closure on it. So there's no gaps. So I'm going to take a step back and come back to this in a second and correct me if my I could be completely wrong here. So if I'm thinking from the shoes of an individual developer like myself or Jason or anybody who's just developing software. And I'm going to assume, which you might have to help correct me. So if you're at a really big company, chances are you're not able to deploy straight to the cloud, or at least that's been my experience, is they typically have it pretty locked down. There's like procedures and reviews to go through and there's a whole organization kind of devoting to that.
所以是的，所以在这种特定情况下，它在某种程度上创造了一个很好的闭环。所以没有缺口。所以我要退后一步，一会儿再回到这里，如果我的，如果我在这里完全错了，请纠正我。所以如果我站在像我自己或Jason或任何只是开发软件的个人开发者的角度思考。而且我假设，你可能需要帮助纠正我。所以如果你在一家非常大的公司，你很可能无法直接部署到云端，或者至少那是我的经验，他们通常把它锁得很死。有程序和审查要通过，有一个完整的组织致力于此。
So if I flip to the other side, if you're a super, super small, like only a single developer or a couple of developers, then you probably are the whole entire stack. And then my guess is there's a sort of gradient in the middle where like you kind of mentioned before this, you know, shadow IT where maybe there's people who are trying to do IT or monitor it, but they're not everywhere. You could get around them. And it's not that you intentionally or unintentionally meant to, it just sort of kind of happens. Where along the spectrum do you find that many of the developers kind of live in? I'm not clear from my side. I've spent most of my life
所以如果我转向另一边，如果你是一个超级超级小的，比如只有一个开发者或几个开发者，那么你可能就是整个堆栈。然后我的猜测是中间有一个梯度，就像你之前提到的这个，你知道，影子IT，也许有试图做IT或监控它的人，但他们并不无处不在。你可以绕过他们。而且并不是你故意或无意中打算这样做，它只是某种程度上发生了。你在频谱的哪个位置发现许多开发者生活在其中？我这边不清楚。我大部分时间都花在
working at relatively large companies where these kinds of things you're talking about have always been of interest, but they've always kind of been handled by someone else or handled by the platform. So if you're building something yourself or in a company that's, let's say sort of medium or small size, how do you sort of figure out like who the right people to contact are? How do you kind of figure out for yourself what are the best development approaches to make sure that you aren't accidentally going to expose all your data to the world? Right, right. So the thing is that, and that's why I kind of connected to kind of an evolution. So there used to be good news for this. There used to be a good answer for your question. The good answer would be, oh yeah, once you have a few controls in your organization basically 90%
在相对较大的公司工作，在那里你谈论的这些事情一直都很受关注，但它们一直都是由别人处理或由平台处理。所以如果你自己构建东西，或者在一家，让我们说中等或小规模的公司，你如何弄清楚谁是联系的合适人选？你如何为自己弄清楚什么是最好的开发方法，以确保你不会意外地将所有数据暴露给世界？对，对。所以问题是，这就是我为什么把它与某种演变联系起来。所以曾经有关于这个的好消息。曾经有一个对你的问题的好答案。好的答案是，哦，是的，一旦你在组织中拥有几个控制措施，基本上90%
of the problem of the risk is gone but that's no longer the the answer you know for the big big corporations um you know that i don't know thes, Amazons, I believe it's so insanely sophisticated there that there's very little chances of a developer adding risk in terms of security because the investment is probably huge. But for the medium-sized and the emerging companies that have to deliver and ship fast, which is probably the majority of the companies these days, there isn't this kind of resources. And also, the times of one solution to rule them all is gone.
的问题或风险就消失了，但这不再是答案了，你知道，对于大公司，嗯，你知道，那些，亚马逊，我相信那里非常疯狂地复杂，开发者在安全性方面增加风险的机会非常小，因为投资可能巨大。但对于那些必须交付和快速发布的中型和新兴公司，这可能是当今大多数公司，并没有这种资源。而且，一种解决方案统治一切的时代已经过去了。
So you can't really buy a system, put it in your network, and now all of your security issues are gone. Because ways to do things are just growing. So just for example, if you look at your machine right now, I mean, ignoring where you currently work at, if you look at your machine and have a small thought, what's in your bash history, assuming you used your terminal? Do you have a.files? If you use Vim, what's in your Vim, VimRC? Do you have any secrets there, any tokens, anything that is maybe issued by a company or organization, but you have it right there. And guess what's the first thing hackers want to steal? Right?
所以你不能真正购买一个系统，把它放在你的网络中，现在你所有的安全问题都消失了。因为做事的方式正在增长。所以仅仅举个例子，如果你现在看你的机器，忽略你目前在哪里工作，如果你看你的机器并有一个小小的想法，你的bash历史记录里有什么，假设你使用了你的终端？你有.files吗？如果你使用Vim，你的Vim，VimRC里有什么？你有任何秘密吗，任何令牌，任何可能是由公司或组织发出的东西，但你就在那里拥有它。而且猜猜黑客最想偷的第一件事是什么？对吧？
Yes, logins and passwords. Exactly. And you know, don't tell me, but by all means, have a look after this. Just, you know, do a last on your C-shell history and figure out what's in there. What's the material? just you know do a last on your seashell history
是的，登录名和密码。完全正确。而且你知道，别告诉我，但无论如何，看完这个后看一看。只是，你知道，在你的C-shell历史记录上做一个last，弄清楚里面有什么。材料是什么？只是，你知道，在你的C-shell历史记录上做一个last
and figure out what's in there what's the material, how many times do you export a token, maybe even an ephemeral token, something temporary but still it gives clues, it gives clues to how systems work and you know
并弄清楚里面有什么，材料是什么，你导出令牌的次数是多少，也许甚至是短暂的令牌，某种临时的但仍然它给出了线索，它给出了系统如何工作的线索，而且你知道
how many of the tokens are temporary and how many of them are permanent and how does one look like and so on and so forth. So all these things are kind of happening on the last mile, which is us, the developers. So you can look at an organization and say, wow, that's a fully secure organization. But the last mile is probably us. We use all the, you know, in terms of R&D, we use the assets, we connect them,
有多少令牌是临时的，有多少是永久的，其中一个看起来像什么，等等等等。所以所有这些事情都在最后一英里发生，也就是我们，开发者。所以你可以看一个组织并说，哇，那是一个完全安全的组织。但最后一英里可能是我们。我们使用所有，你知道，在研发方面，我们使用资产，我们连接它们，
we take on the risk of, yeah, I'm going to use this token and this password and this secret, and I'm going to connect to this external service and to this external machine, and I'm going to store some stuff on my machines. And all these things combined are just, you know, ways that I've adopted to be super productive. And as the world of software grows, the ways to be super productive also get more sophisticated. And that creates an impossible problem for one cyber or security solution to solve. It's basically you need to solve
我们承担风险，是的，我要使用这个令牌和这个密码和这个秘密，我要连接到这个外部服务和这个外部机器，我要在我的机器上存储一些东西。所有这些事情结合在一起只是，你知道，我为了超级高效而采用的方式。随着软件世界的增长，变得超级高效的方式也变得更加复杂。这为单一的网络或安全解决方案创造了一个不可能解决的问题。基本上你需要解决
all of the habits of developers at once? Yeah, I guess I don't, security is not my background or my forte, but I always hear security and depth and layers of security. And I guess this is what you're sort of mentioning, like the last mile of developers. And we were talking at my company a little bit about social engineering
开发者所有的习惯一次性？是的，我想我不，安全性不是我的背景或专长，但我总是听到深度防御和安全层。我想这就是你提到的，像开发者的最后一英里。我们当时在我的公司稍微谈论过社会工程学
and just my takeaway was basically, like if someone targets to social engineer you're kind of hosed like uh the amount of sophistication and some of the attacks that that have been uncovered is just insane that um no matter what you do that uh someone could probably figure out your username and password without you uh kind of knowing that you've turned it over and i guess as're mentioning, if you store stuff on your computer and your dot files, or even just in your history, and they get access to your computer, they're going to learn a lot. And I guess that makes sense. That kind of brings to light to me why you have to have so many layers of security. It's not just the firewall at the outside or the intrusion detection on the inside, but also like even on
我的收获基本上是，就像如果有人针对你进行社会工程学，你基本上就完了，呃，复杂程度和一些已经被揭露的攻击简直是疯狂的，以至于无论你做什么，呃，有人可能在没有你，呃，知道你已经交出它的情况下弄清楚你的用户名和密码，而且我猜正如你提到的，如果你把东西存储在你的电脑和你的点文件中，或者甚至只是在你的历史记录中，如果他们获得了你电脑的访问权限，他们会学到很多。而且我想这很有道理。这对我来说揭示了为什么你必须拥有这么多安全层。它不仅仅是外面的防火墙或内部的入侵检测，而且甚至在
individual computers, like having people have good habits and stuff. Right, right. And you can't not have your dot files, right? Because first of all, dot files indicate a kind of progression, right? Because you're using something that supports 12-factor apps and is considered as a best practice, right? But, and there's like a huge warning here that I think we all miss, is that somewhere we should have a.file that is not meant to be in a repo, but it's laying on our computers. And what's in these.files? I don't know, but I'm quite sure that a hacker learning these best practices, they also want to learn how to abuse these best practices. So I would, I don't know, I would build a script that searches for.env.production.
个人电脑上，比如让人有好的习惯等等。对，对。而且你不能没有你的点文件，对吧？因为首先，点文件表明了一种进步，对吧？因为你正在使用支持12要素应用程序的东西，并且被认为是最佳实践，对吧？但是，而且这里有一个巨大的警告，我想我们都错过了，就是某处我们应该有一个.file，它不打算在仓库中，但它躺在我们的电脑上。这些.files里有什么？我不知道，但我很确定黑客学习这些最佳实践，他们也想学习如何滥用这些最佳实践。所以我，我不知道，我会构建一个搜索.env.production的脚本。
Yeah, I think... And grabbing it from your computer, right? Oh, yeah. I think I took a... I also, like Patrick, don't have a strong background in cybersecurity, but I did take a course on it in university. And I remember at one point someone was... The lecturer was talking about the magnetic hard drives and how when you just erase something,
是的，我想……并从你的电脑上抓取它，对吧？哦，是的。我想我采取了一个……我也，像Patrick一样，没有网络安全的强大背景，但我确实在大学里上过一门课。我记得有一次有人……讲师在谈论磁性硬盘，以及当你只是擦除某样东西时，
it's not actually gone. It's just, you know, some reference to the data is gone because to recover it. And someone started kind of challenging and saying, well, if I do all of these things in this course, then, you know, I'm totally untraceable. I'm totally secure. And the professor had a really insightful answer that always stuck with me. He said, you know, yes, he said, but if you're a criminal, and this is for like cyber forensics type stuff, if you're a criminal, you know, you have to, you know, make sure like in the world of atoms, you're totally, you know, untraceable and in the world of bits, you're untraceable and you didn't leave any footprints and you didn't, you know, and so when you, when you started accumulating all of this, it becomes harder and harder and harder to, to, to get away with something. And so, and so this is also true where there's so many different systems we work with. We, we, we use 10 different languages and we're, you know, having, we're on three different public clouds and there's four different machine types. When you start adding it all up, if you have a problem even once, that could be enough to get access to everything else.
它实际上并没有消失。它只是，你知道，对数据的一些引用消失了，因为要恢复它。有人开始挑战并说，好吧，如果我在这门课中做所有这些事情，那么，你知道，我完全无法追踪。我完全安全。教授有一个非常有见地的回答，一直留在我的脑海里。他说，你知道，是的，他说，但如果你是一个罪犯，这是针对网络取证类型的东西，如果你是一个罪犯，你知道，你必须，你知道，确保像在原子世界里，你完全，你知道，无法追踪，在比特世界里，你无法追踪，而且你没有留下任何足迹，而且你没有，你知道，所以当你，当你开始积累所有这些时，变得越来越难，越来越难，越来越难，去逃脱惩罚。所以，所以这也是真的，我们工作的系统太多了。我们，我们，我们使用10种不同的语言，我们，你知道，有，我们在三个不同的公共云上，有四种不同的机器类型。当你开始把这一切加起来时，如果你甚至有一次问题，那可能就足以获得对其他一切的访问权限。
Right. I think this is completely what's happening right now. And unfortunately, a lot of it is happening in our domain, like in the developer space, because the general sense is that if we get more power and, you know, I can look at Docker just as something that happened that gives us developers more power, because now I can, you know, I know previously I could use VMs,
对。我认为这完全是现在正在发生的事情。不幸的是，很多事情正在我们的领域发生，比如在开发者空间，因为普遍的感觉是，如果我们获得更多的力量，而且，你知道，我可以把Docker仅仅看作是发生的事情，它给了我们开发者更多的力量，因为现在我可以，你知道，我知道以前我可以使用虚拟机，
but now I can, you know, kind of juggle machines and plug and play them and, you know, build so many things in a better way. So I have so much more power using Docker. And all these things kind of shift the power towards the developer and shift the responsibility also to the developer. And the big question is, did you or did we know that this, that happened, that we have more responsibility now? Because as far as we care, you know, we have more stuff to play with.
但现在我可以，你知道，某种程度上摆弄机器并即插即用它们，而且，你知道，以更好的方式构建很多东西。所以我使用Docker拥有更多的力量。所有这些事情在某种程度上将力量转移给了开发者，也将责任转移给了开发者。而大问题是，你或者我们知道这，发生了，我们现在有更多的责任吗？因为就我们而言，你知道，我们有更多的东西可以玩。
I mean, it's, you know, I'm super productive. I'm much more productive than 10 years ago. But did I know that I now have much more responsibilities in terms of security? So, yeah. So I think the answer for that is that I'm seeing, we're seeing that not everyone realizes that, you know, with that extra oomph that we got with all these technologies that we actually have now, we are taking more risk as developers. So that is the, you know, that is the friction that we see.
我的意思是，它是，你知道，我超级高效。我比10年前高效得多。但我知道我现在在安全性方面有更多的责任吗？所以，是的。所以我认为答案是，我正在看到，我们正在看到，并不是每个人都意识到，你知道，随着我们通过所有这些技术获得的额外动力，我们实际上现在作为开发者承担了更多的风险。所以这就是，你知道，这就是我们看到的摩擦。
And the answer is to try to use the same tools that we use to build features and products and to figure out what do we, you know, what do we miss? So I just said, yeah, if I'm a hacker, let me just build a scanner that, you know, tries to find your.env.production, right? So how about we use that and build a developer tool that actually can tell me that before the hacker knows it? So here's a go. Here's an idea. Build a tool that scans for all these files that you know that you have in the back of your head on your computer.
而答案是尝试使用我们用来构建功能和产品的相同工具，并弄清楚我们，你知道，我们错过了什么？所以我刚才说，是的，如果我是黑客，让我只是构建一个扫描器，你知道，尝试找到你的.env.production，对吧？那么我们为什么不使用它并构建一个开发者工具，实际上可以在黑客知道之前告诉我呢？所以这是一个开始。这是一个想法。构建一个工具，扫描所有这些你知道你在电脑后脑勺里拥有的文件。
And that is a tool that you build for yourself and put it in your own toolbox. And now you feel much more secure and now you can work in a safer way. It's like a carpenter working with security goggles, right? So this is how you can actually build the tools for yourself so that you can actually take on more responsibility. So that was basically my thinking, I guess, throughout all of my career. So that every step you need to actually make your toolbox bigger so that you can actually take on more responsibility. Yeah. So when you talk about, I guess, throughout your career, you're saying, thinking about this toolbox, I guess it's probably bad,
而那是一个你为自己构建并放入你自己的工具箱中的工具。现在你感觉更安全了，现在你可以以更安全的方式工作。这就像一个木匠戴着安全护目镜工作，对吧？所以这就是你如何实际上为自己构建工具，以便你实际上可以承担更多的责任。所以这基本上是我的想法，我想，在我整个职业生涯中。所以每一步你都需要实际上让你的工具箱更大，以便你实际上可以承担更多的责任。是的。所以当你谈论，我想，在你整个职业生涯中，你说，思考这个工具箱，我想这可能很糟糕，
but I'll admit it. I don't really spend much of my day thinking about what tools could I add to my toolbox to help make sure that I don't leak secrets. I'm a bad, bad engineer, I guess. But how does someone go from the mindset of like, my job is to sit here and as you were mentioning, faster and faster to ship a product to see what sticks. So what is the phrase to move fast and break things, right? I didn't invent that. And like, how do you go from that mindset to sort of culturing a sense of like, hey, wait a second, I'm taking these risks. And they're really easy to not take these risks. You know, these are the common dot files that people would
但我会承认。我并没有真正花我一天中的大部分时间思考我可以添加什么工具到我的工具箱中，以帮助确保我不泄露秘密。我猜我是一个糟糕的、糟糕的工程师。但一个人如何从像，我的工作是坐在这里，正如你提到的，越来越快地发布产品以看看什么有效。所以移动快并打破东西的短语，对吧？我没有发明那个。而且像，你如何从那种心态转变为某种培养一种感觉，像，嘿，等一下，我正在承担这些风险。而且不承担这些风险真的很容易。你知道，这些是人们会扫描的常见点文件
would scan for. I mean, it makes sense when you told it to me, it seems obvious, but I won't admit that I probably ever thought about it before. How does someone go from my sitting here and just developing code to I also need to have tools in my toolbox for not just developing my code, but for making sure my code is safe and secure. Yeah. So, so actually it's, it's, it can be very simple. I mean, to me, it's, it's, it's very clear and I'll try to give the same clarity in how I think about it. So I remember the day when we used to ship software and zero tests. That was around 2005, 2006 maybe.
。我的意思是，当你告诉我时，这很有道理，这似乎很明显，但我不会承认我可能以前想过它。一个人如何从我坐在这里只是开发代码，到我也需要在我的工具箱里有工具，不仅是为了开发我的代码，而且是为了确保我的代码是安全和可靠的。是的。所以，所以实际上它，它，它可以非常简单。我的意思是，对我来说，它，它，它非常清晰，我会尝试在我的思考方式中提供同样的清晰度。所以我记得我们过去发布软件和零测试的日子。那大约是在2005年，2006年可能。
Yeah, no such thing as unit test. No one even knew about that. And basically you would ship your software, you wouldn't even test it, you know, properly and you'll figure out, yeah, we have a QA somewhere down the line. They'll do the work, tell me what's wrong. And I'll just, you know, wake up and fix the stuff they found. That was life. So, and that was not long ago in terms of, you know, in normal professions, like 15 years in, I don't know, in car making, that's nothing, right?
是的，没有单元测试这样的东西。没有人甚至知道那个。而且基本上你会发布你的软件，你甚至不会测试它，你知道，正确地，你会弄清楚，是的，我们在某个地方有QA。他们会做工作，告诉我哪里错了。而我只会，你知道，醒来并修复他们发现的东西。那就是生活。所以，而且那在，你知道，在正常职业中并不久远，比如15年，在，我不知道，在汽车制造中，那什么都不是，对吧？
So that's, that's 15 years, uh, in software. So that, that was the reality. But since then, in terms of, uh, quality and, uh, QA, I mean, we almost obliterated that, that kind of workflow and we have unit tests andend tests, and so on and so forth. And everyone knows that you need to have coverage. So that's one thing to think about. Another thing to think about is distributed systems, right? So there was a time where we built a server, a service, doesn't matter,
所以那是，那是15年，呃，在软件中。所以那，那是现实。但从那时起，在，呃，质量和，呃，QA方面，我的意思是，我们几乎抹去了那种工作流程，我们有单元测试和端到端测试，等等等等。而且每个人都知道你需要有覆盖率。所以这是要考虑的一件事。另一件要考虑的事情是分布式系统，对吧？所以曾经有一段时间我们构建了一个服务器，一个服务，没关系，
and we deployed it to one single server. And that again was at the same kind of area of years. And maybe we used two. That was like amazing. And the load balancer was kind of a hardware
我们把它部署到了一台服务器上。那也是在同样的年代。也许我们用了两台。那简直太棒了。负载均衡器就像是一种硬件
thing that you had to put out from a box and install it somewhere. And, you know, we never thought about redundancy in the way that we do today. And today it's insanely more involved and so much, you know, so much better. And again, today, what we do is we plan a service. And I mean, almost before the first line of code, we think about how is it going to be deployed in how many instances and how would it fail and so on and so forth. And I think security will go through the same evolution. I mean, what changed? The only thing that changed is the responsibility.
你需要从盒子里拿出来，安装在某个地方。而且，你知道，我们从来没有像今天这样考虑过冗余。而今天，它变得极其复杂，而且，你知道，好得多了。再说一次，今天我们做的是规划服务。我的意思是，几乎在写第一行代码之前，我们就会考虑它将如何部署，部署多少个实例，它会如何故障等等。我认为安全也会经历同样的演变。我的意思是，改变了什么？唯一改变的是责任。
So on the QA story, there was a group of people who were responsible to test your code, but not you as a developer. And on the redundancy side, there was the group of people called IT, not even ops, and they were supposed to make sure your service is always live, which is absurd these days, because how would they even know back then? And I mean, today, you guys just said it. I mean, in some organizations, you build your code and there's a bunch of people who are
关于质量保证（QA）的故事，有一群人负责测试你的代码，而不是你作为开发人员自己测试。在冗余方面，有一群人被称为IT，甚至不是运维（Ops），他们本应确保你的服务始终在线，这在今天看来是荒谬的，因为他们当时怎么可能知道呢？我的意思是，今天，你们刚才也说了。在某些组织中，你编写代码，然后有一群人
responsible to make sure you don't do a mistake or don't put the company in risk. So, I mean, just, you know, just from a history point of view, the story should repeat itself, right? Yeah. I mean, I think, as you mentioned, like a single developer becoming more and more, I mean, in the beginning, there was only the developer and then there was the organization. And then now we're going back to only the developer. So, yeah, I would say it's a fair bet to say that it's going to go back to a combination of people. And we'll see if it I sometimes think that the roles can be embedded within the team. So, you know, we talk about
负责确保你不犯错，或者不让公司承担风险。所以，我的意思是，仅仅从历史的角度来看，故事应该会重演，对吧？是的。我的意思是，我认为，正如你提到的，像单个开发人员变得越来越多，我的意思是，起初只有开发人员，然后有了组织。现在我们又回到了只有开发人员的状态。所以，是的，我认为说它会回到人员的组合是一个合理的赌注。我们会看看它是否……我有时认为这些角色可以嵌入到团队中。所以，你知道，我们谈论
like deploying on Docker or whatever, like, it's not that you have an ops team that is responsible for deploying everything, but maybe you have, you know, a person or a consultant on your team who helps you do it. And it's still the team's responsibility, but there's someone there to help it. So I guess if I hear what you're saying about security, you know, thinking, thinking similarly, like having someone who isn't there to just, you know, send you emails when you've accidentally leaked your password. Um, but actually, you know, help you guys develop, um, good practices and sort of look over what you're doing and make good suggestions and is a shared goal with your team. Yeah, I think that can make a lot of sense. Yeah, and I mean, and you ask how,
比如在Docker上部署之类的，并不是说你有一个负责部署所有内容的运维团队，而是你团队中可能有一个人或顾问来帮助你完成它。这仍然是团队的责任，但有人在那里提供帮助。所以我猜，如果我听到你关于安全的说法，你知道，想法类似，就像有个人不仅仅是在你意外泄露密码时给你发电子邮件。嗯，而是实际上，你知道，帮助你们开发，嗯，好的实践，并审视你们正在做的事情，提出好的建议，并且是与你们团队共同的目标。是的，我认为这很有道理。是的，我的意思是，你问如何，
like how can actually teams can improve and, you know, and take more of that ownership over security. So that's the first step, realization. You know, history repeats itself. And I'm a huge fan of philosophy. And what I see here is a pattern that repeats. And I'm quite convinced it will repeat itself because we are all people and humans. And we collaborate and work in fairly the same way. You know, what's the difference between quality and quality of service, which is actually kind of what
团队实际上可以如何改进，你知道，并承担更多关于安全的责任。所以这是第一步，意识到这一点。你知道，历史总是惊人的相似。我非常喜欢哲学。我在这里看到的是一个重复的模式。我相当确信它会重演，因为我们都是人。我们以相当相同的方式协作和工作。你知道，质量和质量保证（这实际上是分布式系统要解决的问题）与你的安全质量之间有什么区别？所以它们是一样的。所以这是一部分。我个人相信的另一部分是试图灌输回顾和从错误中学习的心态。所以，如果你的公司、你的文化中有这些流程，那么你总是可以使用这些流程来实际拥有，你知道，一个插件，一个空间，嘿，我们正在进行预演或事后总结，让我们谈谈
distributed systems come to solve, and then quality of your security. So it's all the same. So that's one part. And the other part that I believe in personally is trying to instill the mentality of retrospectives and learning from mistakes. So if you have these kinds of processes in your company, in your culture, then you can always use these processes to actually have, you know, a plugin, a space for, hey, we're doing a pre-mortem or a post-mortem let's talk about how
安全在整个图景中是如何体现的，所以我们谈到了冗余和部署，以及容量规划如何，我们谈谈安全怎么样，这意味着有时你可以模拟攻击，有时你可以证明，你知道，证明某个服务是安全的，或者有时你只是，你知道，列出你的风险是什么，这是一个很好的对话开场白。所以如果你有一个计费服务，嗯，你知道，那么你实际上可以陈述你的。你可以在同一个表格中说，你的恐惧是有人可以进入，然后，我不知道，偷走什么？
security is in this whole picture so we talked about redundancy and deployment and how's the you know capacity planning how about we talk a little bit about security which means sometimes you can either simulate attacks sometimes you can either prove that you know prove that a certain service is secure or sometimes you can just you know list what your what your risks are and that that is a great conversation opener so if you have a billing service um you know then you can actually state your. And you can just say in that same form, your fear is that someone can go in and, I don't know, steal what?
信用卡、交易号码等等。所以，仅仅通过在同一个预演、回顾或其他什么形式中陈述对你来说有价值的东西，你知道，你实际上可以开启一个很好的对话，你可能会发现人们甚至没有意识到你正在构建的服务实际上对潜在的攻击者来说具有很大的价值。
Credit cards, transaction numbers, and so on. So just by stating what's valuable for you in that same form of premortem, retrospective, whatever, you know, you can actually start a great conversation and you can discover that people didn't even realize that the service you're building is actually holding a lot of value for a potential attacker.
而这占了工作的一半。是的，你现在描述的，我们已经涵盖了很多内容，但你现在描述的是你提到的那种考虑攻击向量，什么是，你知道，人们可能在哪里攻击？他们会认为什么是价值，那种从局外人的角度思考，不仅仅是，嘿，我正在玩你的服务，而是在审视它，分析我能从中得到什么。然后我决定花多少时间，是仅仅为了让你的网站崩溃，还是为了窃取你的数据，或者这里是否有我可以提取的东西。我想即使是这样也是一种
And that is 50% of the job. Yeah, you're kind of describing now, we've kind of covered a lot of ground already, but you're describing now you were mentioning sort of thinking about the attack vectors and what is the, you know, where could people attack? What would they think about a value sort of thinking about coming from someone on the outside, not just, hey, I'm playing with your service, but I'm looking at it, I'm analyzing what I could get from it. And then I'm deciding how much time to spend, whether it's just to crash your site or to drop your data, or if there's something here, I could extract. And I guess that even in itself is a
有用的思考方式，我正在部署这个对最终用户有价值的服务。但在某些方面，比如更多的个人数据或信用卡，无论什么，那些对向最终用户提供真正出色的体验最有价值的东西，也会成为攻击者非常诱人的目标。我想目标越诱人，你就越需要担心确保你的东西非常安全。对。而且我总是尽量保持非常非常简单。我的意思是，我的意思是，有，你知道，想想你每天在做什么，你知道，
useful way to think about it is I'm deploying this service, which is valuable to end users. But in some ways, like the more personal data or credit card, whatever, those things that might be most valuable to delivering really awesome experiences to end users would also be very juicy targets for attackers. And I guess the juicier the target, the more concerned you have to be with making sure your stuff is very secure. Right. And always, I try to keep it very, very simple. I mean, I mean, there's, you know, think about what you're doing in a day to day, you know,
你的电脑里装满了敏感材料吗？你加密了你的驱动器吗？因为，你知道，曾经，你知道，在我们过去参加会议的时候，我真的看到，我不会说出那家公司的名字，但那是一家大型云公司，两名解决方案架构师只是把笔记本电脑留在椅子上，然后去洗手间。
is your computer filled with, with sensitive material? Did you encrypt your drive? Because, you know, once, you know, in the times when we used to go to conferences, then I literally saw, I won't name the company, but it's a big cloud company, two solution architects just leaving their laptop on the chair and going for the restroom.
我当时看着两台显然贴着公司贴纸的笔记本电脑，它们简直在告诉我，偷我吧，对吧？我的意思是，一旦发生这种情况，如果你没有加密你的硬盘，基本上，只需要五分钟，我就能得到你所有的数据。所以这些是我喜欢思考的小而简单的事情，这些是我喜欢思考的术语。所以它非常非常简单。它与你每天正在做的、让你感到不舒服的事情联系起来，并试着弄清楚那是什么。另一方面，在组织和团队方面，它也非常，你知道，非常简单，就是与你所恐惧的事情联系起来，比如你的恐惧。
And I was kind of looking at two laptops with obviously the company sticker on them, just telling me, steal me, right? I mean, so once that happens, if you didn't encrypt your hard drive, basically, it's just, five minutes and I have all of your data. So these are the small, simple stuff that I like to think, these are the terms that I like to think in. So it's very, very simple. It's connect to the, you know, the stuff that you're doing on a day-to-day basis that you're feeling uncomfortable with and try to figure out what that is. And on the other side is also, you know, in terms of organization and teams, it's also very, you know, very simple is connect to the things that you're fearing from, like your fears.
所以基本上，当你准备部署一个服务时，我敢肯定，作为一名开发人员，你的恐惧是这个服务会宕机，对吧？所以你会尝试弄清楚如何保持它在线，并且，你知道，避免在晚上醒来，因为，你知道，你没有，我不知道，适当地限制某些东西，或者你没有考虑到边缘情况。所以只需增加另一层恐惧，那就是，我认为这个服务正在存储敏感数据，我想陈述这一点。这只是一个与其他人交流并进行头脑风暴、思考你能做什么的简单方法。显然，当你这样做几次后，
So basically, when you're about to deploy a service, I'm sure as hell, like as a developer, your fear is that this service is going down, right? So you'll try to figure out how to keep it alive and, you know, avoid waking up at night because, you know, you didn't, I don't know, throttle something properly or you didn't think of an edge case. So just add another layer of fear, which is, I think this service is storing sensitive data, and I want to just state that. And that is just a simple way to start a conversation with other intelligence people and brainstorm and think what you can do. And obviously, when you do that a few times,
你可能会达到更高级的思考攻击向量的水平，并灌输这种文化，它就会自然而然地发生。是的，我想你是对的。我认为意识到这是一个问题，思考它，这些事情很重要。
you'll probably get to more advanced levels of thinking of attack vectors and kind of instilling this culture and it will just happen from itself. Yeah, I think you're right. I think realizing it's an issue, thinking about it, these things are important.
我觉得它就像你从哲学中说的那样，你知道，一遍又一遍地应用，不仅仅是事情会重演，而且那种学习它的路径首先是意识到有什么东西需要学习，我认为我们在这里讨论的主题是有趣的方法，所以我们谈到了在开发人员的电脑上，你，你知道，拥有一些可以扫描可能你不希望推送出去的秘密，或者你不希望别人在你的电脑上得到的东西。我们谈到了应用程序防火墙和传统防火墙。我们谈到了一点关于SQL注入。所以我们谈到了一点像有人进入
I feel like it's uh like you said from philosophy you know applies over and over again not just that things repeat itself but that kind of the path to learning about it is first realizing there is something to learn and i think the topics we're discussing here are interesting approaches so we've talked about on a developer computer that you you know, having something that scans for maybe secrets that you wouldn't want pushed out or that you wouldn't want someone to get on your computer. We talked about application firewalls and traditional firewalls. We talked about a little bit about SQL injection. So we talked about a little bit like someone getting
你的电脑或偷走你的电脑硬盘。我们谈到了一点关于最终部署的应用程序。还有哪些领域？我的意思是，那里有一个完整的管道，我猜，你知道，不仅仅是开发代码，还有推送代码，服务代码，你知道，像分布式系统本身。还有哪些领域是考虑安全时很重要的？是的。所以有两个利基领域，我会说。我会小心地称这些为利基，但我没有先提到这些是有原因的。
on your computer or stealing your computer hard drive. We talked a little bit about like the end deployed app. What are other areas? I mean, there's a whole pipeline there, I guess, of, you know, not just developing the code, but then pushing the code, serving the code, you know, like the distributed systems themselves. Like what are other areas that are important to think about security in? Yeah. So there's two niche areas, I would say. I would be careful with calling these niche, but there's a reason I didn't mention these first.
所以一个是，我相信，可能是最可怕的，那就是收到一封电子邮件，点击某样东西，然后砰，你的电脑现在被锁定了，所有数据都在里面，你需要付给某人数百万美元。对。所以这就是整个勒索软件的事情。而且是的，正如你提到的，对抗这个的最好方法是实际上，你知道，有意识。所以进行意识培训，确保你知道什么是网络钓鱼。有时是电子邮件，有时在电子邮件方面，
So one is, I believe, maybe the scariest of all, which is getting an email, clicking on something, and then bam, your computer is now locked with all the data and you need to pay someone millions of dollars. Right. So this is like the whole ransomware thing. And yeah, as you mentioned, the best way to combat this is to actually, you know, be aware. So have awareness training and make sure you know what phishing is. And sometimes email specifically, sometimes in terms of emails,
有一些非常先进的电子邮件提供商可以告诉你，听着，这封邮件来自你的组织之外。在这方面我是Gmail的粉丝。你知道，他们可以给你的联系人之外的东西着色。我不知道其他客户端是否存在。我希望有。但这很好，是意识的一部分
there are some email providers that are very advanced that can tell you, listen, this email came from outside of your organization. And I'm a fan of Gmail in that sense. You know, they can color the out of your contacts thing. I don't know if that exists in other clients. I hope it is. But this is a good part of awareness
我认为应该在那里。而且很长一段时间都没有。我的意思是，如果你是一个电子邮件客户端，你正在为企业提供服务，显然你可以识别谁在组织内，谁在组织外，然后只需给我打个电话或告诉我，听着，组织外的人现在正在给你发电子邮件。那是一件非常非常好的事情。而且标记与它们指向的URL不匹配的超链接是另一件让我感到震惊的事情，电子邮件客户端今天竟然不做。对，对，对。显然所有的
that I thought should be there. And it wasn't there for a long while. I mean, if you're an email client and you're giving a service to an enterprise and obviously you can identify who's in the organization, who's outside, and then just give me a call or tell me, listen, someone from outside the organization is now sending you an email. That's a great, great thing to know. And flagging hyperlinks that don't match the URL they point to is another one that shocks me that email clients don't do today. Right, right, right. And obviously all the
DNS拼写错误，这很有趣。你有一个公司名称，然后有人改了一个字母，也许把一个I变成了一个大写的I，看起来像一个L。然后你就有了一些看起来很熟悉但并不是的东西。所以这也，你知道，这也是某件事，我不知道该不该称之为有趣，但当你意识到你可以这样做时，你就去花四块钱买下那个域名。然后你手里就有了你知道某人可以用来进行攻击的东西，所以基本上，顺便说一句，这是我加入的几乎每家公司都会做的事情，我查看域名，然后我去买下所有看起来相似的域名，并把它们交给运维和IT人员，让他们拥有这些域名，你知道，只需买下它们，这样就没有其他人可以买下它们了，而且
DNS typos, which is fun. You have a company name and then someone changes a letter, maybe turns an I into a capital I, which looks like an L. And then you have something which looks familiar, but isn't. So that also, you know, that is also something, I don't know if to call it funny, but it's when you realize that you can do it, then you go and buy the domain for like four bucks. And then you have something in your hand that you know someone can use for for attacking so basically by the way this is something i do in almost every company i join i look at the domain and then i go and buy all the similar looking domains and hand them over to the ops and it people to just have these domains you know just buy them so no one else can buy them and
而且非常便宜，所以我真的鼓励每个人为他们的公司这样做。所以是的，这是一个我称之为利基的攻击类别，因为它们非常具体。另一个实际上会让那些从事嵌入式系统工作的人感觉更好，也许更多，因为在那里，有一类语言被认为是“不安全的”。我想那是一类在这些日子里诞生的语言。但这个想法……你正要攻击我，不是吗？哦，不，不，不，不。
and it's very cheap so i i really encourage everyone to do that for their companies. So yeah, so this is one category which I would call niche of kind of attacks because they're very specific. And the other one is actually that would feel nice to people who works with embedded systems, maybe more, because in there, there's a category of languages which are considered unsafe. I guess that's a category of languages that was kind of born these days. But the idea... You're about to attack me, aren't you? Oh, no, no, no, no.
这个想法是，我的意思是，对我来说，这很奇怪，因为我记得用C和C++编程就像昨天一样，还有汇编语言。我来自这一代。对我来说是今天。而这些日子，这些语言被描绘成不安全的，你知道，基本上是因为它们默认情况下没有为你的内存使用提供正确的检查，所以这类语言，你有一个完整的，我不知道，正确使用的领域，所以你实际上可以构建安全的软件。
And the idea is that, I mean, to me, it's strange because I remember programming in C and C++ like it was yesterday and also assembly. I'm from this generation. It's today for me. And these days, these languages are kind of portrayed as unsafe and, you know know basically because they are not providing the right checks for your memory usage out of the box by default so this class of languages you have a whole i don't, domain of proper usage so you could actually build secure software.
但它在某种意义上是安全的，当你，我不知道，当你把软件放在心脏起搏器上时，那么没有黑客可以真正黑掉它，我猜，或者宇宙飞船什么的。所以是的，有整个安全领域致力于确保这些东西尽可能安全。仅仅从开发人员的角度来看，当你构建这种软件时，最容易使用的工具之一是模糊测试器（fuzzer），它基本上意味着它是一种你可以使用的工具或库。
But it is secure in the sense that when you, I don't know, when you put the software on a pacemaker, then no hacker can actually hack that, I guess, or a spaceship or whatever. So yeah, so there's this whole domain of security geared towards making sure these things are as safe as possible. And just to look at this from a developer point of view, then when you build this kind of software, so one of the most accessible tools to use is a fuzzer, which basically means it's a kind of a tool or a library that you can use.
我试着用简单的术语解释它。如果你有一个函数应该接收一个字符串和一个整数，例如，那么这个工具会查看这个函数，分析它，并尝试注入，比如暴力破解世界上所有的字符串，比如巨大的字符串，带有二进制字符的字符串，带有Unicode字符的字符串，并且会通过暴力破解来做。它不会试图在这方面变得聪明。如果它是一个整数，显然它会尝试溢出它或给它一些坏数字，基本上它需要一些时间，然后它会想出一个对你的软件来说很糟糕的组合，所以基本上你会在几周又几周又几周的时间里进行模糊测试
I try to explain it in a simple term. If you have a function that is supposed to receive a string and an integer, for example, then this tool would look at this function, analyze it, and try to inject kind of brute force all of the strings in the world, like huge strings, strings with binary characters in them, strings with unicode characters in them, and will do it by brute forcing. It won't try to be smart about it. if it's an integer obviously it will try to overflow it or give it some bad numbers and basically it takes some time and then it will come up with a combination which is bad for your for your software so basically you'll be fuzzing
然后你就能看到是否有任何结果。这个结果对你来说将是金子，因为你只是用时间换取了一些非常敏感的东西。如果这个，例如，如果这是一个宇宙飞船，对吧？所以这是一个完整的安全类别，非常针对开发人员。而且，你知道，在嵌入式领域或针对开发人员，而且，你知道，在嵌入式领域或那些，你知道，在那种意义上可能变得非常非常昂贵的领域。
this for weeks and weeks and weeks and then you'll be able to see if, you know, there's any result. And this result would be gold for you because you just exchange time with something which is very sensitive. If this, for example, if this was a spaceship, right? So that is a whole category of security and very geared towards a developer. And also, you know, in the realm of embedded or towards a developer and also, you know, in the realm of embedded or things that are, you know, in that sense can become very, very costly.
仅仅为了对此进行即兴发挥，对于那些可能没有意识到的人，所以如果你运行一个模糊测试器而你的程序崩溃了，有许多不同的原因导致它可能是一个问题。所以第一个原因是，显然，就像如果你正在运行一个航天器或服务，如果它崩溃了，那么你就有，你知道，停机，对吧。所以有人可以不断发送格式错误的数据并使你的系统崩溃。如果他们这样做足够多，那么你就有了一种拒绝服务问题，或者，你知道，更糟。所以以这种方式，你知道，这有点像第一类问题。然而，第二类问题是，有时它崩溃是因为你没有正确检查数据。而崩溃实际上可能导致缓冲区溢出，允许某人利用
Just to riff on that for a second, for people who may not realize, so if you run a fuzzer and your program crashes, there's a number of different reasons why it could be a problem. So the first reason is that obviously, like if you were running a spacecraft or a service, if it crashes it down, and then you have, you know, an outage, right. And so someone could keep sending malformed data and crashing your system. And if they do that enough, then you have a sort of denial of service problem or, you know, even worse. And so in that way, you know, that's kind of like the first class of problems. The second class of problem though, is that sometimes it crashes because you're not checking the data properly. And the crash can actually lead to a buffer overflow that allows someone to exploit
你的代码，然后实际上读取你的电脑或内存的内容，并实际上窃取结果，这比仅仅让它崩溃要糟糕得多。所以运行一个模糊测试器并发现这些东西是非常有用的，因为很多时候它是不明显的，特别是如果你依赖另一个库来做像JSON解析或任何类型的数据消费之类的事情，而有人可以在那里输入。如果那个库中存在一个问题，你使用它是因为你喜欢它有很多方便的功能，你可能会让自己面临一系列你没有意识到的问题。
your code and then actually read contents of your computer or your memory and actually steal results, which is much worse than just crashing it. And so running a fuzzer and finding those things is super useful because many times it's unobvious, especially if you depend on another library for doing something like JSON parsing or any kind of data consumption and someone can feed in there. And if there's a problem in that library, which you used because you liked the fact that it had a lot of convenient functions in it, you could be opening yourself to a whole host of problems that you didn't realize.
对。你刚才说得比我好得多。但是是的，我，你知道，你可以，你可以，你可以声称，我不知道，也许，你知道你可以你可以声称，我不知道，也许，你知道正如你知道我们有SpaceX和所有这些，也许有更多的开发人员正在被调用
Right. You just said it's much better than me. But yeah, I, you know, you can, you can, you can claim, I don't know, maybe, you know you can you can claim I don't know maybe you know as you know we have SpaceX and all these maybe there's many more developers that are being called
并运送到航天器，这些日子比你知道当只有NASA时。所以我不知道。也许模糊测试器会流行起来。是的，所以我们谈到了，好的，其他几个利基领域。然后我知道人们提到的另一件事
and shipping into a spacecraft these days than you know there was when there was only NASA so I don't know. Maybe fuzzers will come into fashion. Yeah, so we talked about, okay, a couple other niche areas. And then one of the other things I know people kind of mention
是你经常看到的，有人会发布一份报告，他们扫描了GitHub，发现，你知道，10,392个地方有人存储了他们的数据库密码。什么是，所以显然这就像一个巨大的问题。这是否是你看到人们在做的事情，即把代码本身推送到一个存储库，而他们在那里无意中放了一些东西？是的。我的意思是，首先，快速免责声明，这是我们在Spectral所做的一部分。哦，好的。
is you see every so often is someone will publish a report where they scanned GitHub and they found, you know, 10,392 places where someone had their database password stored. What are the, so obviously like that's a huge problem. Like, is that something that you see people doing is pushing code itself up to a repository where they've put something in there unintentionally? Yeah. I mean, first of all, quick disclaimer, this is part of what we do at Spectral. Oh, okay.
好吧，我想我为你准备了一个。是的，顺便说一句，只是为了闭合一个小圆圈，你知道，当我能推荐它时，推荐它真是太有趣了。所以我经历过，我不知道，从汇编语言开始，可能经历过几乎每一个程序和语言，包括Haskell和Erlang以及一些古怪的语言。而在Spectral，我们使用Rust，
Well, I guess I teed one up for you there. Yeah, and by the way, just to close a small circle, which, you know, it's so much fun to recommend when I can recommend it. So I've been through, I don't know, since assembly, probably through almost every program and language, including Haskell and Erlang and some wacky languages. And at Spectral, we use Rust,
在模糊测试、不安全语言方面，它应该是安全的。据我所知，它是。没有一个早晨我没有醒来看着代码说，这是一种了不起的编程语言。它给了我圣杯。所以只是为了鼓励人们去尝试Rust。这是一种了不起的语言，你知道，对我来说，它和C++一样高性能，而且表达能力强，没有任何缺点。太棒了。回到你的问题。所以是的，人们确实倾向于犯这些错误。我的意思是，这实际上是目前情况的反映，那就是有太多的工具，太多的技术，这些天对开发人员的要求太多，以至于有太多的机会犯错误。而犯错误是，是的，让我给你举个例子。
which on the fuzzing, unsafe languages part of things is supposed to be safe. And as far as I can tell, it is. And there hasn't been a morning where I didn't wake up and look at the code and say, this is an amazing programming language. It gives me the Holy Grail. So just to encourage people to just try out Rust. It's an amazing language that is, you know, for me, it's as performant as C++ and as expressive with none of the disadvantages. It's amazing. And back to your question. So yeah, so people do tend to do these mistakes. And I mean, it's actually a reflection of the situation right now, which is there's so many tools, so many technologies, so much is being asked from a developer these days that there's so much opportunity to make a mistake. And making a mistake is, yeah, let me give you an example.
它正在使用一个你认为的IDE，让我们用一个具体的例子。所以你有IntelliJ。而IntelliJ喜欢把一些设置保存在一个叫.idea的文件夹中。据我所知，任何人都可以说，这个文件夹是干净的。它是安全的。所以如果你喜欢，你实际上可以把它推送到你的GitHub仓库，它是公开的，一切都很棒，因为你得到了保证。
It's using an IDE that you think, let's use a concrete example. So you have IntelliJ. And IntelliJ likes to save some settings in a folder called.idea. And as far as I can tell and anyone else can tell, this folder is clean. It's safe. So if you like, you can actually push it to your GitHub repo, which is public and everything is great because you get a guarantee.
从IntelliJ的角度来看，常识性的做法是，是的，确保它是干净的，并让你发布你的设置，这样如果其他人拿走这个项目，那么他们就会在他们自己的IntelliJ编辑器中得到一个配置良好的环境。这就是几乎每个开发人员都有的理解。但这里有一个转折。还有插件。一些开发人员会选择安装各种插件，非官方的。我亲眼见过一个插件，它实际上做的不仅仅是搜索，
The common sense thing to do from IntelliJ's point of view is, yeah, is make sure it's clean and let you publish your settings so that if someone else takes the project, then they will get a nicely configured environment for them in their own IntelliJ editor. So that's the understanding that almost every developer has. But here's the twist. There's also plugins. And some developers would choose to install various plugins, unofficial ones. And I've seen in my own eyes a plugin that is actually doing something more than a search,
像某种超级搜索之类的。基本上，我见过一个项目，开发人员推送了他们自己的私人设置，在那里，他们安装了这个插件。而这个插件所做的是打破了我猜IntelliJ有的不变性，即这个文件夹必须是干净的。所以基本上插件保存并缓存了开发人员在这个文件夹内的搜索词。哦，不。这有点好笑，因为你可以看到开发人员在发布项目之前是如何清理它的。
like some hyper-search something. And basically, I've seen a project where a developer pushed their own private settings, and in there, they had this plugin installed. And what this plugin did is break the invariant that I guess IntelliJ has, that this folder has to be clean. So basically the plugin saved and cached the search terms of the developers inside this folder. Oh no. And it's a little bit funny because you could see how the developer cleaned up the project before publishing it.
所以你会看到搜索结果就在一个公共仓库里。你会看到Amazon，然后是AWS，然后是EC2。然后你会看到实际的Amazon密钥和秘密。所以基本上，我所看到的是开发人员在发布之前试图清理项目的整个历史。他们搜索了实际的秘密，以便从代码中删除它们。但插件……哦，他们是在尝试。正是如此。
So you would see the searches right there in a public repo. You would see Amazon, and then AWS, and then EC2. And then you'll see the actual Amazon key and secret. So basically, what I've watched is the entire history of the developer trying to clean up the project before publishing it. And they searched for the actual secrets in order to remove them from the code. But the plugin... Oh, they were trying. Exactly.
插件记录了一切并把它丢进了这个.idea文件夹里，它本应该是干净的。这就是每个开发人员都有的理解。所以他们推送了项目，发布了它。基本上，因为它是一个.文件，我猜他们也都在Windows上。而在Windows上默认情况下，你看不到隐藏文件什么的。是的，完全不知道它
The plugin recorded everything and dropped it inside this.idea folder, which is supposed to be clean. That is the understanding that every developer has. So they pushed the project, published it. And basically, because it's a.file, I guess they were all also on Windows. And by default on Windows, you don't see hidden files or whatever. Yeah, completely didn't know about it
它在那里坐了至少六个月，直到我们向我们看到它暴露的公司报告了它，是的，在那之后我们得到的那个故事基本上是，你知道，他们有
it was sitting there for at least six months until we reported it to the company that we saw this exposed in and yeah, the story that we got after that was basically, you know, they had
矿工和闯入云端什么的，所以这对他们来说是一团糟，所以这只是一个小的例子，你知道，有太多的自由，太多的技术，太多的东西可以使用和实验，但你并不总是得到，你知道，最好的产品，基本上这个归结为采用了一些插件，看起来很酷。但我猜插件的开发人员没有把安全放在第一位
miners and breaking into the cloud and whatever, so it was a mess for them so this is just one one small example of uh you know so much uh there's so much freedom so much technology so much to use and to experiment with uh but you don't always get uh you know the the best offering uh basically this one was down to adopting some plugin, which looks cool. But I guess the developer of the plugin didn't have security first
或者没有真正理解或意识到有这种协议，即这个文件夹需要是干净的。是的。好吧，我想这作为一个很好的过渡，当我们在这里总结时，让你谈谈Spectral是什么以及它做了什么。是的，所以Spectral是一个为开发人员准备的工具。
or didn't really understand or realize that there's this kind of agreement that this folder needs to be clean. Yeah. Well, I guess that serves as a pretty good transition as we sort of wrap up here for you to talk a little bit about what Spectral is and sort of what it does. Yeah, so Spectral is a tool for developers.
它是一个安全扫描器。它试图做我们今天谈论的那种事情，那就是遵循开发人员的习惯，成为最好的伙伴，并确保每个人都可以为自己使用它，并确保他们扫描他们的工作并扫描他们的电脑，并确保他们不犯错误。我们说错误是因为这就是它。你可以说漏洞，那是另一个术语，但基本上在Spectral，我们50%来自网络安全，50%是纯工程师。所以我们喜欢保持这种生产力和安全的平衡。所以我们只是称之为错误。
It's a security scanner. And it tries to do kind of things that we talk about today, which is follow the habits of a developer and be the best buddy and make sure that everyone can use it for themselves and make sure they scan their work and scan their computer and make sure they don't do mistakes. And we say mistakes because that is what it is. You can say vulnerability, that's a different term, but basically at Spectra, we're 50% coming from cyber and 50% pure engineers. So we like to keep this balance of productivity and security. So we just call it mistakes.
我认为这就是它。而错误是出于好意而犯下的事情。基本上，一整类错误是，你知道，使用和放错敏感数据、秘密、密码、凭据等等。而且，你知道，把不同的文件放在你不想让它们在的地方，并意识到我们作为一家公司正在努力意识到开发人员的习惯和工作流程，并确保总有一个很好的解决方案。所以我认为这周或下周，我们将发布一个开源产品。
I think that is what it is. And a mistake is something that was made on good intention. And basically a whole class of mistakes is, you know, using and misplacing sensitive data, secrets, passwords, credentials, and so on. And, you know, placing different files somewhere you don't want them to be and realizing we as a company are trying to realize the habits and the workflows of a developer and making sure there's always a great solution for that. So I think this week or next week, we're going to release an open source product.
我们要把它开源。它所做的是，我不想操之过急，但它所做的是承认整个保险库或点文件的使用并不完美。所以它承认了这一点，并给了你一个很好的工具，它是开源的，
We're going to open source it. And what it does, I don't want to jump the gun, but what it does is acknowledge that the whole usage of vaults or dot files is not perfect. So it acknowledges it and gives you instead a nice tool, which is open source,
你可以构建它并做任何你想做的事情，它给了你一个干净的方法来实际处理秘密，从保险库中获取秘密，或者从你的磁盘或任何其他服务中获取它，并在你的硬盘上留下零足迹。所以基本上一切都在内存中。所以这是我们确定的开发人员正在努力解决的问题。
and you can build it and do whatever you want with it, which gives you instead a nice tool, which is open source and you can build it and, you know, do whatever you want with it, which gives you a clean way to actually handle secrets, grab secrets from a vault or grab it from your disk or from any other service and leave zero footprint on your hard drive. So basically everything is in memory. So this is something that we identify that developers are struggling with.
所以是的，所以这只是我们做的另一件事的例子，我们将在下周推出。哦，不错。我得留意一下。那么Spectral作为一家公司呢？所以你说你们是50%的网络安全，50%的工程师。
So yeah, so this is just another example of something we do and we will launch next week. Oh, nice. I'll have to keep an eye out for that. And then what about Spectral as a company? So you said you're a 50% sort of cyber, 50% engineers.
你们在招实习生吗？你们在招聘吗？在Spectral作为一家公司工作是什么感觉？所以你说你们是50%的网络安全，50%的工程师。你们在招实习生吗？你们在招聘吗？在Spectral工作是什么感觉？哦，是的。所以首先，我们在招聘。基本上，我们有Rust工程师、Go工程师和Node.js的职位。我想你可以说我们一直在招聘。我的意思是，我们总是愿意结识很棒的人。
Are you guys looking for interns? Are you hiring? What is it like to work at Spectral is a company. So you said you're a 50% sort of cyber, 50% engineers. Are you guys looking for interns? Are you hiring? What is it like to work at Spectral? Oh, yeah. So first of all, we're hiring. Basically, we have kind of positions for Rust engineers and Go engineers and Node.js. And I guess you could say we are always hiring. I mean, we're always willing to meet great people.
至于公司，你知道，COVID的事情导致我们完全远程。但幸运的是，我们，就公司内部的经验而言，我们中的一些人根据定义来自分布式公司。所以我们能够为成为一个很好的远程优先或分布式
And in terms of the company, it's, you know, the COVID thing kind of caused us to be fully remote. But lucky enough, we're kind of, in terms of the experience in the company, then some of us come from distributed companies by definition. So we were able to create a really great infrastructure for being a nice remote first or distributed
公司创造一个非常好的基础设施。是的，所以我们非常高效，确保我们拥有分布式的所有优势，而没有缺点。是的。不错。不错。所以你们认为你们会，我的意思是，你不必回答，
company. And yeah, so we're being super productive, making sure we have all of the advantages of distributed and zero of the disadvantages. And yeah. Nice. Nice. So do you guys think you'll, I mean, you don't have to answer,
但你认为你们会保持虚拟，还是你们认为当这一切结束时你们会回到某种正常的事情？所以是的。所以我们基本上总是试图考虑平衡，并首先考虑人。所以你知道有，首先，它是找到正确的工具。所以Slack是正确的工具吗？
but do you think you will stay virtual or you guys think you'll go back to a somewhat normal thing when this is all over? So yeah. So we basically try to always think about the balance and think about the people first. So you know there's, first of all, it's finding the right tools. So is Slack the right tool?
电子邮件是正确的工具吗，对吧？所以我们发现的是我们使用Discord。这基于一个简单的论点，如果游戏玩家真的很喜欢那个平台，那么程序员可能也会，我们发现它实际上证明了自己，因为当你共享你的屏幕并共享多个屏幕时，人们可以观看其他所有人的屏幕
Is email the right tools, right? So what we found is we use Discord. And that was on a simple thesis where if gamers are really liking that platform that coders probably would and we found that it actually proved itself because when you share your screen and share multiple screens and people can watch everyone else's screens
我的意思是编辑器，对吧？编写代码而不是游戏。所以你有零延迟，你有非常好的音频，一切都运行良好。所以你意识到整个事情是为共享游戏而优化的，它对于共享代码和做，你知道，结对编程，所有这些事情来说绰绰有余。而且你也有房间，我们实际上做了几个房间，只是几个，不多，就像在真正的办公室里一样。所以我们有每个人都想要的房间，但被占用了，对吧？同样的挫折感。
and what I mean is editors, right? Writing code and not games. So you have zero latency and you have really great audio and everything just works. So you realize that this whole thing was optimized for sharing games and it's more than enough for sharing code and doing, you know, pair programming, all these things. And you also have rooms, which we actually made a few rooms, just a few, not too many, just like in a real office. So we have rooms that everyone wants, but are taken, right? The same frustrations.
所以基本上，我们的Discord类似于一个真正的办公室。你可以直接进入一个房间，进入一个对话，这真的真的很有趣。所以这是我们意识到并实验过的一件事，对我们来说真的很有效。但是的，我们正在努力创造一种平衡。而且，你知道，在可能的情况下，进行物理会面。我们一直在把这当作一个问题来思考。
So basically, our Discord resembles a real office. You can just drop in a room, drop into a conversation, and it's really, really fun. So that is one thing we realized and experimented with and really works well for us. But yeah, we're trying to create a balance. And also, you know, when possible, meet physically. We're always thinking about this as a problem.
我们如何解决它？有点像工程师，像一个工程问题。不错。这是一个很好的启发式方法，如果游戏玩家喜欢它，工程师可能也会。是的，我认为这是一个很好的收获。是的，太棒了。那么你个人呢？你在社交媒体上吗？
How do we solve it? Kind of like engineers, like an engineering problem. Nice. This is a great heuristic that if gamers like it, engineers might too. Yeah, I think that's a great takeaway. Yeah, it's great. And then what about you personally? Are you on social media?
你有什么，我想你可能还在做其他事情。有什么你想和大家分享的吗？哦，是的。所以我在GitHub、Medium和Twitter上。我是John Dot，J-O-N-D-O-T。是的，我有点，我试图同时在所有地方，但这行不通。
Do you have any, I think you might be doing some other stuff. Anything you want to share with people? Oh yeah. So I'm on GitHub, Medium and Twitter. I'm John Dot, J-O-N-D-O-T. And yeah, I kind of, I'm trying to be on everything at the same time it doesn't work.
所以我正在分配我的精力。所以你会看到我活跃，你知道，在GitHub上的一段时间和在Twitter上的一段时间。所以我只是负载均衡。我不能并行做所有事情。所以是的。好的。非常酷。
So I'm dividing my energy. So you'll see me active, you know, periods of times on GitHub and periods of times on Twitter. So I just load balance. I can't do everything in parallel. So yeah. All right. Very cool.
好吧，谢谢你的时间，Dotan。我们真的很感激。那是一个非常棒的安全高级概述。我玩得很开心。谢谢你来到节目，完美，我也是。音乐由Eric Farm Mellow提供。Programming Throwdown是在知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0许可下分发的。你可以自由地
Well, thank you for your time, Dotan. We really appreciate it. That was a really awesome high-level overview of security. I had a good time. Thank you for coming on to the show perfect me too music by eric farm mellow programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Share Alike 2.0 license. You're free to
分享、复制、分发、传输作品，进行混音、改编作品，但你必须提供对Patrick和我的署名，并以相同方式共享。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide an attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
分享、复制、分发、传播本作品，进行重混或改编，但您必须注明我和帕特里克的署名，并以相同方式共享。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。